nos dicen tienes un sólido que sabes que
en su mayor parte tiene cloruro de sodio
sospechas que también puede tener algo
de yoduro de sodio cloruro de potasio o
cloruro de litio cuando analizas una
muestra encuentras que contiene 73% de
cloro por masa es la muestra cloruro de
sodio puro sino que otros compuestos
tiene probablemente pausa en el vídeo y
vean si pueden resolverlo les será muy
útil tener una tabla periódica a la mano
para resolverlo la forma en que vamos a
abordar esto es pensar en cada uno de
estos compuestos y tratar de descubrir
el porcentaje por masa de cloro para
hacer esto tenemos que pensar en las
masas molares de los diferentes
elementos que forman cada compuesto y
para calcular la masa molar de cada
elemento nos vamos a fijar en la masa
atómica promedio de manera que sepamos
cuántos gramos tenemos por mol si hay un
molde ese átomo del sodio cloro yodo
potasio y litio la masa atómica promedio
del sodio es 22.99
cloro es 35.45 del yodo es ciento 26.90
del potasio es 39.10 y del litio es 6.94
ahora podemos guardar la tabla periódica
aquí ponemos los diferentes compuestos y
aquí voy a escribir el porcentaje de
cloro por masa primero analicemos el
cloruro de sodio y voy a escribir esto
en un color diferente para hacer las
cosas interesantes del cloruro de sodio
bueno la masa molar del cloro es 35.45
gramos por mol y luego lo dividimos
entre la masa molar de todo el compuesto
esta es la masa molar del sodio 22.99
gramos por mol más la masa molar del
cloro de nuevo 35.45 gramos por mol
sacamos la calculadora y escribimos
35.45 dividido entre abrimos paréntesis
22.99 + 35.45 cerramos paréntesis esto
es igual
parece que va a ser un poco mayor al 60%
y de hecho esto es suficiente para que
continuemos porque si es aproximadamente
61 por ciento entonces podemos ver que
es muy diferente de 73% por lo que es
muy claro que la primera pregunta es la
muestra cloruro de sodio puro tiene como
respuesta no porque tiene un porcentaje
diferente de cloro por masa de la que
tendría el cloruro de sodio puro así que
debe estar mezclado con algo que tiene
un mayor porcentaje de cloro por masa
veamos los otros candidatos podemos ver
el yoduro de sodio así que en el yoduro
de sodio
cuál es su porcentaje de cloro por masa
bueno pues no tiene cloro por masa así
que esto es cero porque si mezcláramos
yoduro de sodio con cloruro de sodio se
reduciría el porcentaje de cloro por
masa no lo incrementaría así que podemos
descartar esto ahora veamos el siguiente
cloruro de potasio lo voy a escribir por
acá su porcentaje de cloro va a ser la
masa molar del cloro 35.45 dividido
entre la masa molar de todos
la masa molar del potasio es 39.10 más
la masa molar del cloro es por supuesto
35.45 y podemos tratar de calcular esto
pero incluso cuando vemos los números
nos damos cuenta de que el denominador
aquí es más grande del que teníamos para
el cloruro de sodio y tenemos el mismo
numerador así que si el denominador es
más grande significa que vamos a tener
un valor menor a 61% y como tiene un
porcentaje menor de cloro por masa si
estuviera mezclado entonces tendría un
promedio menor a 61 % no subiría a 73%
así que podemos descartar este también
ahora veamos al último candidato tengo
un buen presentimiento con este porque
con algo tiene que mezclarse veamos el
cloruro de litio cuál es el porcentaje
de cloro por masa va a ser la masa molar
del cloro 35.45 dividida entre la masa
molar del compuesto escribo de una vez
la masa molar del cloro a la que le
vamos a sumar la masa molar de litio que
es bastante pequeña 6
94 gramos por mol así que de nuevo
cuando comparamos con el cloruro de
sodio tenemos el mismo numerador pero
claramente tenemos un denominador más
pequeño este valor es más pequeño que
este valor y el otro número es el mismo
así que esto tiene un denominador menor
lo que significa que el valor total va a
ser más grande que 61 % permítanme sacar
la calculadora tomamos 35.45 dividido
entre abrimos paréntesis 6.94 35.45
cerramos paréntesis es igual a
aproximadamente 84% de cloro por masa
esto tiene aproximadamente 84 por ciento
de cloro por masa este funciona si
tenemos cloruro de litio mezclado con
cloruro de potasio va a incrementar el
porcentaje de cloro por masa por arriba
del 61 por ciento y de hecho con base en
estos valores de 61% 84% y 73 % ustedes
podrían encontrar cuál es el porcentaje
que
la muestra de cloruro de sodio y cloruro
de litio si suponemos que ambas son las
únicas cosas que tiene